Tes
T
??
>> These extremely rare but
damaged motion pictures of Mark
Twain were taken at his home in
Connecticut
in 1909, a year before his death
. A copy of the film along with
first
editions and thousands of the
celebrated writers letters and
manuscripts were part of the
Mark Twain project.
Its aim is to painstakingly edit
and
publish the book of Twain's huge
output Twain's daughter
bequeathed her father's papers
to the University of California
at Berkeley in 1962.
The extensive collection is
hidden away in small offices on
the top floor of Bancroft
Library.
For three decades editors have
been pouring over more
than 10,000 letters, plus
notebooks, story and book
manuscripts and newspaper
clippings seeking to find
the real Mark Twain and to make
all of his work accurate and
accessible.
>> This is your literary
heritage here in our files. It
has to be edited. It has to be
performed in some form if it's
going to be transmitted into the
future.
>> Robert hurst, the general
editor has
devoted his entire professional
life since 1967 to Twain, who he
sees as a towering talent in
language and humor.
>> I still hear my editors
laughing out loud during the
hall because they are
reading something which they
probably read a dozen times
before but it still alive, it's
still funny no matter how many
times you read it.
>> Many academics would argue
that Twain is still America's
best-loved, perhaps its best
writer.
Prof. Frederick crews recently
retired from Berkeley's English
department.
>> Mark Twain appeals to
academics and non-academics to a
degree that you can't find
matched in any other writer.
He grew up with the country.
He represents the Midwest, the
Far West, even the New England
establishment.
He went from being a rough
frontier
humorist to being the darling of
gentle culture. Which of course
he made fun of.
>> Robert paca Browning, another
of the
project editors is convinced
Twain is worth special treatment
as an American writer and
personality.
Using materials from Berkeley's
collection he has put together
an exciting display of Twain's
life and work at the
university's Blackhawk Museum.
>> The language that you and I
speak,
with its peculiar American
qualities was put down on paper
by this man.
>> Notice his handwriting...
>> At the museum visitors
immerse themselves in issues
Twain wrote about from racial
equality to love. A passionate
love letter to his future wife
is here for everybody to read.
>> I love love love love love
you... And multiplied by 150...
And so loving you I note your
faults
and knight them with my love
>> What do you think Mark Twain
feels about this wonderful
woman?
>> He was really in love with
her.
>> Twain spent a lot of time in
the lecture circuit to gain fame
and money.
His lecture notes from 1896 help
explain the crucial passage in
Huck Finn publish 12 years
earlier where Huck is debating
whether to turn in Jim as a
runaway slave
>> Huck is preparing to turn Jim
in, yet he finally concludes
that he cannot do that. His
heart wins out. And his
conscience suffers a defeat.
This was the most popular
component of his lecture on this
grand tour of the world.
[Applause]
>> so, good morning.
I am so happy to see all of you.
So glad to be able to welcome
you to the Library of Congress
this morning and
to the ninth annual Jonah school
cuff
Eskin Memorial lecture. Today is
going to be more of a
presentation and a conversation
and we are delighted to have all
of you.
We are also delighted to have
our author, fillet stead with us
and before we get started with
the rest of the program I've got
a couple remarks for you.
I'm Leanne Potter I direct
educational outreach here at the
Library of Congress and along
with my colleagues in
educational outreach and our
young reader center we want to
welcome you and we also want to
shout out to you because we know
who all of you are.
Before I do the rollcall of the
various schools in the room
though I want to
mention that this week is
children's book week. It is the
longest running national
literacy program or initiative
in the United States. It is
sponsored by the children's book
Council as well as every child a
reader, and along with schools
and libraries
around the country, this week is
dedicated to celebrating the joy
of reading. So we are happy that
you are with us today to help us
celebrate the joy of reading.
All of you, before you leave
will be receiving a copy of this
year's book week poster, so make
sure you get those on your way
out.
They were illustrated by Jillian
to amaki and given to us by the
children's book Council so a
nice thank you to the children's
book Council.
Also I want to make another
shout out,
thank you to my colleagues to
Karen Jaffe, to Sasha dowdy, to
Monica Valentine, the rest of
educational outreach as well as
the multimedia team for making
this morning possible. Thanks,
you guys.
So we have six, seventh and
eighth graders here with us from
school without walls at Francis
Stevens..
. We have sixth-graders from
Washington global public charter
school...
We also have sixth and seventh
graders from Stuart Hobson
middle school.
We have sixth-graders from St.
Patrick's Episcopal school.
We also have students from
Northern
Virginia including students in
grades three through six from
the river from cooperative
school in Alexandria..
. And, and I guess I should say
this a little louder, we also
have seventh and eighth graders
from the Mark Twain middle
school... In Alexandria.
We are also live streaming this
program.
And we know that we've got
schools and individuals in
various parts of the US watching
so if you guys want to turn
around and waved to them so they
know we are glad they are tuning
in.
[Background chatter]
>> and I really need to do..
. We have some interns in our
young readers center who did
some homework last week to find
as many middle schools in the US
that are named for Mark Twain as
they could and they
sent out special notes to those
schools telling them about this
event. So hopefully we've got
some other Mark Twain schools
tuning in.
I'm excited about that. So thank
you all for coming.
And by the way, because we are
live streaming the program there
will be a
recording available, so if you
really get into the program
today you can watch it again
later and show your friends and
family okay? You will all do
that, right?
Because the Library of Congress
has a
YouTube channel and I know you
all follow it. And we are on
Facebook.
So, today's program is about
Mark Twain but it is just sort
of about Mark Twain.
How many of you, raise your
hands if you think you know a
thing or two about Mark Twain.
Okay. All right. Some good hands
going up.
So as you learn from the video
that we showed you, Mark Twain
was a writer. He was a lecturer.
He was a humorist. He was also a
publisher. And we are going to
learn a little bit
more about him today but we are
also going to focus not just on
Mark Twain,
but really we are going to focus
on the work of this guy and his
wife, so Philip
Stead is with us today and he's
got an incredible story to tell
you about Mark Twain that's very
closely connected to the papers
of Mark Twain that you got a
glimpse of in the video.
And with all of our programs
here at the Library of Congress
we like to make sure that we
understand what the connection
to the library and its
collections might be, with
whatever topic we are focused
on.
So we did a little digging and
not only are there Mark Twain
papers in the Bancroft Library
out in
California but there's some
terrific Mark Twain materials
here in the Library of Congress.
One of them is up on the screen.
In 1874 Mark Twain who of course
his real name was Samuel
Clemens, he wrote a letter to
the librarian of Congress and he
did so because he had written a
series of sketches and he wanted
to ensure that his work was
being copyrighted. You can go
ahead and hit the next slide.
So he is writing to, this is in
May, this is in May 1874. And he
is writing to the then librarian
of Congress, Ainsworth Spofford.
He says dear Sir I  include a
cover of a pamphlet which I
designed also the title page of
the pamphlet upon the contents
of which I likewise desire
copyright.
Fees, one dollar enclosed, very
truly yours, Samuel Clemens.
So I have to say we love it when
we come across things like this
in the library's collection. So
a handwritten letter from Mark
Twain related to copywriting
some of his work.
But not only does the Library of
Congress hold original letters
but the library also has an
enormous collection of
newspapers and magazines and
many many many literally
millions of them are available
through the library's
chronicling America website.
And the next slide shows you one
of those political cartoons in
one of those
magazines, Harper's weekly, that
shows Mark Twain as well and I
know that in your textbooks and
other materials
sometimes you often see things
like the political cartoon, but
you miss the context. You miss
that it originally appeared in
the newspaper and that's the fun
part of looking at original
sources is you see where they
originally came from. I want to
say one more thing about the
video that we watched.
We were so excited about this. A
couple years ago the library
entered into a partnership with
WGBH TV Boston, it's
a public TV station, and because
of the partnership the American
archive of public broadcasting
was established and through the
American archive of public
broadcasting website you can
access literally
thousands of public television
programs like the one we
watched. So when we started
digging around the website it
came across that entire film.
It's a lot longer than what we
saw, related to Mark Twain. So
we were pretty excited.
So another shout out to the fact
that the library's collections
come in a huge variety of media
from motion picture films to
newspapers and periodicals to
manuscripts, library collections
are so much fun. They are not
just books.
But if they were books and you
happen to go on the library
website and you happen to do a
search on Mark Twain in the main
card catalog guess how many
times you would find Mark
Twain's name?
Millions, but about 3000...
There are about 3000 books in
the library collection that are
either written by Mark Twain or
about Mark Twain. That's a lot.
3000. That's incredible. And
they are not just in English
either. Lots of those materials
are in
languages other than a gli
English okay so enough about the
Library of Congress and its
collection.
But what I love most about all
of those materials and the
reason we wanted to highlight
them is to really emphasize to
you that the materials that are
in the library often speak to
us, they inspire us, they are
the ideas and thoughts and
often the voices of people not
only living today but people who
lived in the past.
And our speaker today certainly
has a story in that vein to tell
us.
So I'm going to do my
introduction of Philip now.
So here we go. It is my great
pleasure to introduce
our very patient and
award-winning
author, Philip Stead who with
his
illustrator wife Erin Stead
wrote the exceptional and unique
book, the per lining of prints
Olemargarine
[applause]
>>...
so I'm on record not telling you
that now.
I absolutely never skipped
middle or high school. So I'm an
author and also in illustrator.
I've either written or
illustrated
about 15 different books with
about five or six more to come
in the near future. These two
books are the books that I made
with my wife Erin.
Erin I coucould not be here
today but she was the artist in
all three books and also the
artist for the Mark Twain
collaboration that I'm going to
be talking about today.
A little bit about myself before
I begin. I'm from the state of
Michigan. Has anybody here ever
been to the state of Michigan?
That's not too bad.
I love Michigan. One of the
reasons I love Michigan is
because there's so much water.
I grew up down here near
Detroit, so
people from Michigan like to
show their hands when they are
talking about where they are
from because
Michigan is shaped like a
mitten, but Detroit is down here
and now I live way up there, do
you see the red dot up there?
I live way up there and then do
you see an island of sort of
right above that a big Island?
So remember the island. We are
going to come back to that in a
minute.
I think it is important to know
where a person or where an
author is front because I think
something about where
you are from will inevitably
sort of creep into the types of
things you make.
I think that is absolutely true
of Mark Twain, who as you heard
in the video was from all over,
but really I believe he is from
Hannibal Missouri.
That is where he was born. He
was born along the Mississippi
River.
And I think there is something
about being from the place that
has infected everything he's
written.
When you live along the river I
imagine you are always seeing
people coming and
going and there's constant
motion and things coming into
town and out of town.
When I read Mark Twain's work
that's what sticks out to me.
There's always a coming and a
going in his books and his
stories. They are always
traveling stories.
I think the water is important
to me too. Michigan is
surrounded by water.
And this is right, this may be
five minutes from where I live
PA people think of Michigan and
they imagine something more like
Ohio, flat farmland but when I
think of Michigan I think of
beaches and I think of big open
expanses of water and when I
want to be...
When I want to be quiet and I
want to think about my thoughts
and think about my writing I go
to the water and I sit in quiet
places near the water.
I live in an old farmhouse and
beside the old farmhouse is a
big red barn.
My wife Erin and I have turned
to the red barn into an art
studio. So this is the inside of
the studio.
And the upstairs when you walk
upstairs is just a library of
all books.
So when we don't have ideas we
just go
upstairs and sit and hear other
people's ideas. And once we've
got an idea we go back stairs
and sit at our desk and we begin
to drop.
Anybody here consider themselves
an artist? Yeah.
So I think I was 10 years old..
. I think I was 10 years old
when I was given my first
drafting table. A drafting table
is one of the tables that sort
of lifts up like this so you can
draw closer to your face.
And I think it's really
important as an artist or
author, either one to have a
space that you work.
And it does not have to be as
big and open as this barn. It
can be a corner in a room or a
closet. I remember when I was
very little I used to go in my
closet and lock the door and
that's where I'd work on my
projects. It's important to be
alone with yourself sometimes.
That brings us to Mark Twain.
And the story of how the story
came to be.
So in the year 1879 Mark Twain
was in a
hotel room in Paris and he was
telling a story to his own
children. This is something that
he would do almost every night.
We know that because he would
write about these moments in his
diaries and journals.
And way it would work is one of
the daughters would bring a
magazine or newspaper. They
would open up to a page and
point to an image.
And from the image, Mark Twain,
it was Mark Twain's job to come
up with a story for his
daughters and sometimes it was
successful. Sometimes it was not
so successful.
But we never really had any
actual
written evidence of any of these
stories that survived to the
present day.
So fast-forward all the way to
the year 2011.
There is a man named Dr. John
Byrd, who was a professor from
North Carolina and he was out at
that archive that we just saw in
the video in
Berkeley California and he was
doing research for a Mark Twain
cookbook.
He wanted to write a cookbook
based on food and recipes that
could be found in Mark Twain's
writings.
So he had the researchers
pulling out any file folder that
had anything at all to do with
food.
So there was one folder just
labeled
Oleomargarine which today we
would just call margarine and we
find it at the grocery store
kind of like butter. We always
had margarine in our
refrigerator when I was a kid.
When they open up the folder
instead of finding anything
about food what they found were
16 pages of handwritten notes
for this children's story that
Mark Twain had told his
daughters in Paris that night.
This was an enormous news in the
Mark Twain universe.
Because it's not every day that
you
find something brand-new from
the most famous and important
American writer who has ever
lived.
Interestingly enough though, in
some point in the hundred plus
years between the original
telling and when it was
discovered somebody had actually
pulled it out of the archives,
thought that maybe it was a
little bit illegible that people
would not be able to read it and
decided
to type the whole thing on a
typewriter and stick it back in
the folder and forget about it.
So this thing had been
discovered before but the first
and who discovered it the first
time did not realize the
importance.
So this was what was given to
me. It was not a completed
story. It was notes for a story.
And I was asked to please find a
way to complete Mark Twain's
original idea.
So this is a daunting task.
But right away I began making
written notes on this original
document.
Sometimes I agreed with what
Mark Twain, the ways in which
Mark Twain was telling the
story.
Sometimes almost immediately in
fact I
found ways to take issue with
what Mark Twain was doing, for
example Mark
Twain had right on the very
first page a main character in
the story named Susie
which is also the name of the
daughter and the character was a
kangaroo. I felt that this was a
mistake that he had made.
Mark Twain love kangaroos, which
you can actually learn a lot
about Mark
Twain and that is one thing that
comes up again and again, Mark
Twain love kangaroos.
But as a storyteller that works
specifically in children's
literature like I do, I know
something about kangaroos that
he doesn't, which is that if you
put a kangaroo in your story,
you just made
your story in a very specific
place, in a very specific
country. What country is that?
Exactly so every kid everywhere
knows
that kangaroos are from
Australia and I really didn't
think that Mark Twain wanted to
set the book in Australia.
So I crossed off kangaroo and I
made the character into a skunk.
Which has made some Mark Twain
professors very angry with me.
So what I got was 4 1/2 pages of
notes.
And at the end of the last page
the story just ends. There is no
official ending to the story,
there's just the point at which
he stops taking notes.
And there was never a clear
answer as to whether the final
pages of the manuscript were
missing or if Mark Twain never
got around to writing them, or
maybe there never was an ending.
I am of the opinion that there
actually never was an ending to
this story because this is a
story that Mark Twain was
telling out loud, probably over
the course of several nights.
So there didn't need to be an
ending. It was the kind of story
that just
continued to have new material
every night when he would sit
down with his children.
But that doesn't really work if
you're trying to make a book.
A book needs to have an ending.
So you can see my own
handwriting at the end. That was
a very first thing I wrote for
this project where I get to the
ending and I write then what?
And that was my task, figuring
out then what.
So for me, that meant going very
far away.
And very far away for me meant
an island in the middle of Lake
Michigan.
So you remember the island that
was just north of where I live.
That is called Beaver Island.
And I had never been to Beaver
Island, which is not unusual
because very few
people have ever been to Beaver
Island. This is what it looks
like from the
airplane that I had to take as I
was leaving the island.
There are very few buildings. It
doesn't look anything like
Washington DC. There is a tiny
tiny town at the very far end.
And that's it, there's about
three buildings and a
lighthouse.
There's one road that cuts
through the middle of the
island.
So I originally arrived in that
kind of boat, I had my bicycle.
I wrote all the way to a cabin
that was
owned by a friend of mine, the
cabin had no phone. It had no
Internet. It had no television.
It had no radio.
And I decided I was going to
stay at this cabin until I had
written something. It's always
the hardest part of any
project I think is the beginning
and I can put off working on
something forever if I don't get
to it right away.
So that's why I ended up on this
island. As I'm riding my bike
around this
island though, I kept
encountering these signs along
the side of the road.
And the signs were all talking
about this man named James Jesse
strange.
Who I had never heard about and
I knew nothing about the history
of Beaver Island before I
arrived there with my bicycle.
This is where the story...
The story of Beaver Island is
strange but it's also where the
story of the making of this book
becomes very strange.
In the 1860s, the Mormon church
was led by a man named Joseph
Smith.
Joseph Smith died and then there
were several people who were
sort of vying for control of who
would be in charge of the Mormon
church.
So there was a man named Brigham
Young who took a bunch of his
followers out to
the state of Utah and that's why
so many followers of the Mormon
church still live in Utah today.
But then there was also this man
named James Jesse strange who
took his followers to Beaver
Island.
When he arrived at Beaver Island
he decided that he had had a
revelation
from God and that revelation was
that he should be named King,
king of Beaver Island.
This was very funny to me that
there was a king of Beaver
Island that I had never heard
of.
I learned shortly thereafter,
writing my bike down the road I
end up at a different sign that
says this is the spot where
James Jesse strange issued a
particularly unpopular
proclamation and then he got
himself killed.
So this again was very funny to
me.
And it seemed like exactly the
kind of story that Mark Twain
himself would have
been very interested in hearing
tbecause Mark Twain was always
interested in how American
history, American politics,
American religion are mixed
together to make one sort of
uncomfortable story. So I didn't
know what to do with all this
information.
It seemed important to me. It
seemed important because it was
something that I thought Mark
Twain would be interested in. It
also seemed important because it
was a story about a king and a
kingdom and here I was working
on a fairytale that was about a
king and a kingdom.
And so I could not figure out
exactly how but I nknew I wanted
these things to go together and
I was worried that I was already
sort of going off on a wrong
direction and
Mark Twain maybe would not be so
happy with me. But then my very
last day on the island
I pull a book off the shelf, so
again I'm at a library. A much
smaller library, but a library
just inside this little cabin, I
pull the book off the shelf and
a page falls out.
The book was a little paperback
of stories and essays by Mark
Twain. And this quote was on the
page that fell out.
It says, narrative should flow
as flows the brook down through
the hills and the leafy
Woodlands.
, it's course changed by every
boulder
it comes across and by every
grasp clad
gladly spurred the projections
to its path, it's service
unbroken but the
course not stayed by rock and
gravel in the bottom of the
shoal places. A brook that never
goes straight for a minute but
goes and goes briskly. Sometimes
on grammatically and sometimes
fetching a horseshoe at three
quarters of a mile around and at
the end of the
circuit flowing within a yard of
the path it traversed an hour
before. But always going and
always following
at least one law, always loyal
to that law, the law of
narrative which has no law.
And I love the last sentence,
the law of narrative which has
no law.
And I really felt like I was
Mark Twain giving me permission
to tell this story
in any way that was necessary.
In a really felt that that was
the way that Mark Twain would
want me to tell this story.
But then began, after I came
back from the island I get
something down on paper, it's
really not a finished story
yet but at least I got something
and I really feel like I needed
to do some more research to
really understand who Mark Twain
was.
So there were sort of two ways
to approach how to write the
story.
One would be to try to predict
every single word that Mark
Twain would have said. And right
away I felt like that was a
recipe for failure. There was no
way to really know over 100
years later what Mark Twain
would have said but what I could
do is get to know who Mark Twain
was as best I could
and if I could no who Mark Twain
was that I might be able to tell
a story
that he would be happy with,
that he would
be proud of, that would honor
the spirit of Mark Twain instead
of trying to be literal aabout
the way he would have told the
story. One of the first stops
that my wife and I took was to
this house. So this was Mark
Twain's house in Connecticut.
This was where he lived when he
wrote many of the, his most
famous works.
It is the house that his
children grew up in.
It's a big beautiful elaborate
house, so big that I really
could not fit it all into a
picture so I'm just showing you
one little piece of it.
This is Mark Twain's personal
writing room.
This is my favorite place in the
house. It's got a billiard
table.
The desk in the back is where he
would sit and do his writing.
What I really loved about this
house is that even though it is,
today it is a
museum and even though it is a
big beautiful
elaborate house, it really still
felt like a home. So when you
walk in you really like this is
a place where a family that
loved each other lived. You
could imagine the stories being
told. It did not at all feel
like a museum.
Another piece of research that
was
really important, there are
actually two more pieces I want
to talk about.
One is the autobiography of Mark
Twain, which was published in
three volumes and we stack them
up together it is about this
tall.
What is so important about the
autobiography of Mark Twain is
that he had stipulated he did
not want it published until 100
years after his death.
The reason being is that he had
put all of his grievances into
that autobiography, all the
things
he was feeling irritable about,
all of the things that were
bothering him maybe, there was a
whole section about copyright at
the Library of Congress that he
was upset about...
And he was able to put
information down
in a very honest way that he may
have
felt inhibited, more inhibited
if it was something for
publication while he was still
alive.
In addition to that he didn't
actually write the biography.
What he did is, he spoke it.
He tried and failed several
times in
his life to work on his
autobiography and toward the end
of his life he realized the best
way for him to go about it was
not to start with the day
of his birth and write down
every single instance along the
way until his eventual death.
What he wanted to do is wake up
in the morning and before he
even got out of bed, just start
speaking about whatever it was
that was on his mind. And
somebody else in the room would
be writing it down. This was
hugely important for me.
Because the story I was writing
began as what we would call a
piece of oral history. So it was
a story that was spoken out
loud in real time between Mark
Twain and his daughters. And
here I had pages and pages and
pages of Mark Twain oral
history. And I think we all know
that the way
that you speak out loud is
different from the way that you
write on paper.
And there might be some overlap
between
the two, but I really needed to
get to know the Mark Twain that
spoke aloud and that's a much
harder Mark Twain to find.
The other piece of research that
was really important for me was
a biography written by Mark
Twain by his 12-year-old
daughter Susie.
This was probably the most
important
piece of, the most important
original document that I came
across.
Here we have a quote from that
biography. So she is 12-year-old
and she writes about her father.
He could not bear to hear anyone
talk about himself. But he could
listen to himself talk for hours
without getting tired.
So I could find no other
instance of anybody writing
critically about Mark Twain.
Anybody that was willing to
acknowledge what kind of flaws
did this person have.
Although Susie thought her
father was
very funny, she thought he was
very brave, she thought he was
very intelligent, she also had
critiques of her father and I
wanted to know those critiques.
Mark Twain would also be writing
down notes in his own journals
and diaries about Susie.
So here is one that says
apparently Susie was born with
humane feelings for the animals
and compassion for their
troubles.
That was one of my favorite
quotes that
I came across because that's
when I recognized that if this
was a story that Mark Twain was
telling
to his own children and to Susie
in particular who I think was
his favorite
daughter, and Susie was a child
who had a lot of love and
compassion for animals, then
loving
compassion for animals should be
a part of this story even if
it's not a part of the original
note.
Here's another quote from Susie.
And this quote is actually at
the very beginning of the book
when you open up the book, it
says I have wanted Poppa to
write a book that would reveal
something that was kind of
sympathetic nature.
This as I'm talking right now I
think that this was actually
probably the most important
single piece of information that
Erin and I stumbled across.
Because Mark Twain, you have to
imagine he's not just a famous
author, he's the most famous and
important person on the entire
person on the entire planet when
he was alive. Is less like a
famous author and more
like say, kanyw West he was the
Kanye West of his day. And so
because of that I think it was
very difficult for Mark Twain to
be
honest when in public. He felt a
real burden to always be funny.
I think he felt a burden to
always be really smart. He
wanted to be the smartest and
funniest man in the room but he
had a hard time revealing the
part of himself that was kind
and the part of himself that was
vulnerable.
And I felt that those parts of
himself would be the kinds,
would be the parts
of himself that he revealed if
he was telling a story just to
his own family.
So this is what my writing looks
like. And I kind of cringe at
the idea that
my own notes will end up someday
at the Berkeley archive or the
Library
of Congress because my notes
look a lot like my own middle
school homework.
This is the very first passage
from the book.
This is a note written by me
that sort
of explains how I'm going to
tell the story and the way I
imagined myself telling the
story was that I imagined
Mark Twain was there with me and
he was
telling me the story and now
Mark Twain is gone and it is my
job now to tell it
back to you and I'm going to
tell it in my own way but I'm
going to be as faithful as
possible to the man who told it
to me in the first place.
So now I'd like to talk to you a
little bit about how the artwork
was made.
So, Aaron would normally do this
part of the presentation. She's
at home with our 10 month old
baby right now so I'm going to
do my best at telling her half
of the story.
For Aaron, the most important
part of
the process was coming up with
the main character.
She really felt that there was
no way she could proceed with
this project until she knew
exactly what this character
looked like, exactly how the
character moved.
In this case, she really wanted
the
character to have two things
that are very difficult to put
into the same person. She wanted
the character to look vulnerable
and compassionate.
She also wanted that character
to look brave.
And these two things are not
necessarily opposites but they
are difficult things to put into
the same face.
So Erin spent nearly 3 months
working on this single drawing.
She would draw it and draw it
again and
eventually she came to this
image of our main character,
Johnny, that she was happy with.
One thing that Erin does to find
a
character is that she will
actually sculpt to the character
with clay.
For Erin that's easier sometimes
then
just trying to draw on the empty
white page.
She gets her thumbs in there and
start moving around, what does
the nose look like, what does
the eye look like.
What does the character look
like when you turn it. Does it
look good from all angles.
And once she has got a clay
heaf=dad, this is about 3 inches
tall in real life and once she
has got that finished...
She can move it around and draw
from it. That way you are not
always having to use your
imagination.
Erin uses all old-fashioned and
traditional materials, which is
one of the reasons I think we
were asked to work on the
project.
Mark Twain, when Mark Twain was
alive and writing the most
common form of book illustration
was probably woodblock printing.
In its day, it would have been
in almost every book that you
see had those images. These days
it's much less common but
it's the way that Erin continues
to work so on the right side
here we have her carving knives
that she uses for carving wood
block and on the left are just
her pencils that she uses to
finish the images.
So these are Erin's paints and
her brayer's and what is called
a Baron, a little circular
object is called the Baron.
The way that Erin works as she
will carve a wood block.
She will add ink or paint to the
wood block. Using one of those
prayers. It's kind of like a
paint roller.
And
she will press a piece of paper
onto the wood block and take the
circular Baron and with the
pressure of her own hand will
press the ink from the wood
block onto the paper.
In the center there is Erin's
color chart.
So there are one, two, three, 15
colors there.
That's every color that Erin is
going to use in the book.
Before Erin makes a single image
what she does is decide the
entire color palette for the
entire book.
So this is one of Erin's wood
blocks this is one of the wood
block that was used to make the
cover image.
So, she carved that big shape,
that sort of all smeared in red
right now, that is the Dragon.
Underneath the dragons had is
the
lineead is the lion after she
presses think she pulls up the
paper and it looks something
like this and the final
step is several hours just with
a pencil box where she starts
filling in all the details. So
this is the image. This is the
cover image for the poor
leapurloining.
Typically you would always be
carving away things but one
thing Erin likes to do is add
ink directly onto the block and
sort of wipe it softly away just
with a paper towel and by doing
that she can get an image that
looks kind of like this with
these soft edges
for the Brown and the soft edges
for the cloud and then becomes
an image that looks like this.
So one of the challenge that
Erin was facing was what was the
setting for this book? it was
told originally in 1879. We are
illustrating it at this time in
2014, 2015, 2016. But it's a
fairytale at the same time.
And fairytales are not usually
set, well in Australia for one.
They are also not set in the
United States typically. We kind
of felt that Mark Twain would
want to buck the trend and he
would want the book set in the
US. So what we decided to do is
bridge the
gap between Mark Twain era and
our own era and to set the book
in what is known as the
dustbowl. So, the middle of the
country in the 1930s basically.
A really desolate, dusty place
and we thought it was perfect
for the kind of story that Mark
Twain would tell.
So if you guys see the house up
there
in the upper right corner,
throughout
the book, Erin dropped in little
things that were... She would
call them Easter eggs. Things
for people that really love Mark
Twain to find so they could
engage with the book in a
special way. So the house is
actually based on the house that
Mark Twain was born in, which is
seen here.
The Queen in this story, does
not show up until later on in
the story was actually based on
Mark Twain's wife, which some
people have noted.
There was one final piece of the
creation of the artwork that
really was giving us trouble for
a long time.
There were certain elements that
we
really wanted to be carved in
wood and printed, but they were
just either
too intricate to carved by hand,
or it would just take us too
long.
So, what we ended up doing was
using a laser to carve the wood.
Which involves a lot of me
standing and watching this
machine work. This is what I'm
looking at there.
All of the chapter titles in the
book, so chapter 2 regarding
parades, chapter
1, in which we are introduced to
our
luckless hero, all of the
chapter titles were carved into
wood using this laser machine.
There were also these long
proclamations, the proclamation,
the
unpopular proclamations of the
King, that would have taken us
literally months to carved by
hand that we were able to carve
in maybe 45 minutes using this
machine.
These are some of my favorite
pieces of artwork in the book.
This is what the king's
proclamation looks like in the
final book.
This is what one of the chapter
titles looks like.
Maybe my favorite individual
carving in this book is actually
on the endpaper.
So an endpaper is the part of
the book, the very first thing
when you open the book and the
very last thing you see when you
close the book.
And in most books this will just
be a solid color. Or maybe it
will be plain white.
But Erin and I love to do
something special for the
endpapers whenever we can so we
wanted to bring the whole
project back to where it began.
We wanted to be able to see a
little bit of what Mark Twain's
actual writing looked like.
So we took some original pages
of Mark Twain's work. We had
them digitized.
Then we were able to feed those
into
the laser Carver and Mark
Twain's actual writing started
to get spit out by this laser
Carver directly into the wood.
And this is an image of Erin
pulling a print from Mark
Twain's handwriting. So these
are some of my favorite pieces
of artwork.
So that brings us to the
conclusion.
One of the questions that I get
more than any when I'm talking
about
this book is which part of the
book was Mark Twain and which
part of the book is yours?
And the obvious answer is, the
most obvious answer is that the
ending is my. The last few pages
of the book are completely mine.
But in truth, that doesn't
really tell you the story
because all throughout the
text, he and I are
sort of interweaving and
sometimes it is hidden speaking
and sometimes it is
me speaking and I worked very
hard and it was very difficult
for me to find a way to balance
the two voices.
My favorite example of something
that neither Mark Twain nor
myself but is also both is this
chicken.
So, the chicken is my favorite
character in the entire book.
And the chickens name is
pestilence and famine.
And so as I was doing my
research on Mark Twain, one of
the things I discovered was that
Mark Twain always had cats in
his house.
Cats and cats everywhere. When
he lived on the farm in L Myra
New
York there were cats in and out
of the house and the writing
studio and the cats always had
strange names.
One of those cats was named
pestilence and famine.
Or, and we could never really
figure this out, there were two
cats, one that
was named pestilence and one
that was named famine. The
reason we couldn't figured it
out is because nobody had
bothered to put a
comma where you would need one
and we couldn't find a
satisfactory answer as to
whether there were two cats or
one cat.
But Erin and I thought it was
funnier if there was only one
cat and the cat had two names.
And so that's why the chicken
was introduced into the story as
pestilence and famine.
One chicken with two names. That
is my favorite example of
something that is both a little
bit of Twain and a little bit of
me and a
little bit of Erin, too, and an
example
of the kind of thinking that we
were using as we were making
this project.
>> I love this story. Isn't it a
great story?
[Applause]
>> I am really glad that you
made a point of mentioning how
you start the book. I want to
read you guys something real
quick.
He says at the very beginning
it's the note from one of the
authors..
. And he showed you his
handwriting version of this, but
the part that I
really get a kick out of is most
likely you don't know me and
you've never heard
my name, said too fast or
otherwise chances are you have
heard of my friend, Mark Twain.
He is the one who told me the
story. I love that.
I have a feeling you guys have
some questions for him.
I love this notion that
something that he has just
shared with
you either about his work or the
story itself probably spoke to
you and you have some questions.
So we have got four microphones
all around our room.
And when you raise your hand and
one of my colleagues..
. Identifies you, if you would
take the
microphone and say your name and
then ask your question, that
would be great. Why don't we
start right here.
>> Hi I am Jaden and I wanted to
ask...
What do you, what do you inspire
to be most like Mark Twain?
>> Um..
Well if I could grow a mustache
like Mark Twain I think that
would be pretty great.
I think I learned a lot about
Mark
Twain and as I was working on
this and one thing that I really
admire is that Mark Twain was
really well known for
being able to stand up in front
of people and he would sort of
stand and wait for everybody to
get
really quiet, then he would just
start talking and he could tell
a story like that.
And that really is impressive to
me because it took me three
years to write this story and I
think Mark Twain could have done
it in about 15 minutes.
So that's what I aspire to be.
I aspire to be somebody who can
just get up, tell a story and
have it be perfect on the first
try.
>> Good answer.
I want to mention as well for
those of you who are watching
the live stream if you want to
ask a question you can
through Twitter if you use the
hashtag
TwainLOC if you are on twitter
and you want to ask a question
if you use the
hashtag TwainLOC my colleague
Sasha has her phone ready and
she can be on the lookout for
any of those questions.
Okay how about we go, do we have
a question back there or not?
Great.
>.
> Hi my name is Eleanor and I
was wondering what the
connection between all the
characters was and how they were
all connected.
>> The question is how were all
the characters connected. So
this is a difficult one to
answer
because Mark Twain sort of had
his own
way in his notes of connecting
the
characters but then I had my own
ideas for how the characters
ought to be connected but there
were certain characters that
were the same throughout. So the
character of Johnny, we were
very faithful to the way that
Mark Twain wrote about that
character. Also the character of
the Queen, who I
think was, we based it on Mark
Twain's
wife who he loved very much. But
I think that even if he was not
quite thinking that, that was a
character that he was
particularly in love with.
But there were so many different
options. One of the things I
love about this story is there
were so many pieces of
information that were missing.
And that is what was really
exciting as a storyteller
because there were so many
pieces missing it allowed us to
make the connection and put
things together in a way that
felt appropriate to us.
>> Great.
>> Hi, my name is Cooper and
what made you like Mark Twain so
much?
>> So that's an interesting
question
because there were times when I
would say that I didn't like
Mark Twain very much.
We spent so much time working
with him as if he were a real
live person that we started
to feel that Mark Twain was
almost like a family member.
So you love your family, but
sometimes you just really can't
stand your family either.
And the more that we read about
Mark Twain and the more we had
to spend time with him there
were times when we just felt
like maybe it would be better,
Mark if you would leave and we
could work on this thing by
ourselves for a little while.
But he never left and now I feel
like Mark Twain is permanently
living in my spare bedroom.
[Laughter]
>> My name is Zoe.
I was wondering what is your 10
month old baby's name?
>> My 10 month old baby's name
is
Adelaide, which is actually a
city in Australia.
So Australia has come back into
the conversation.
>> All right
>> My name is Ty and I had a
question
about when you went into the
house did you feel like a
flashback or anything
that he felt inside that could,
you could have put in your
books?
>> You mean like in Mark Twain's
house?
>> Yes
>> so a little bit.
The funny thing is that when you
walk in the house it really does
feel like there are ghosts in
the house and it's not a house
that I would want to be hanging
around and after dark. I will
say that.
>> Hello my name is Avery.
And was the title of your book
Mark Twain's title or did you
make that title?
>> That's a very good question.
So Mark Twain didn't leave a
title.
All he wrote was the word
oleomargarine on the top and so
it was our job also to come up
with the title.
Purloining is my editor's
favorite word, she has two
favorite words, should one is
that one which if you don't know
what it
means it is something like
stealing,
kind of like kidnapping in this
case, her other favorite word is
defenestration
which means to throw yourself
out a window, but I worked
tirelessly to try to get the
second word into the book and
was never able to do it.
>>
My name is destiny and my
question was, is it like a
spiritual connection with Mark
Twain or is he still alive?
>> So, Mark Twain died in I
think it was
the year 1910, but for me he is
very much still alive. And so I
guess, yeah you would call it
kind of a spiritual connection.
>> My name is Suleman and my
question is if those aren't the
characters then how did you pick
which characters to put on the
cover?
>> So that was up to my wife
Erin to decide.
And all of the important
characters in the book are
there. So, the characters that
have either speaking roles or
play some other sort
of important role, and there are
a lot of animals in the book
that are sort of I guess you
could call them background in
the story.
And so it was, Erin was trying
hard to put all the most
important characters which would
include the chicken, the skunk,
the lion, on top of the tiger
there was the weasel, the weasel
was very important to the
telling of the story and of
course the Dragon
which was so big she could not
fit him onto the front cover so
he goes all the way to the back
cover too.
>> My name is Austin and I was
wondering
how many graphs did you have
todrafts did you do?
>> Another good question my very
first
draft was the version of the
book I wrote when I was
on the cabin at Beaver Island
but I did not stop writing the
entire time we were working on
the book.
And so I began writing it's a
time of 2014 and we finish the
book and January 2017.
So around 2 1/2 years of writing
and rewriting and rewriting and
the way that I work I do not
start at the beginning
of a draft and work all the way
to the end. I have the entire
thing in front of me
and I change a little bit
here and there and go back to
the middle and change a little
bit there. So I can't tell you
exactly how many drafts but I
can tell you I was constantly
working, constantly changing.
>> Hello my name is Wesley and I
was wondering if Mark Twain had
an influence on any of your
other books.
>> I love that question.
So did Mark Twain have an
influence on any of my other
books?
I think he did not necessarily
have a direct influence on my
books but I think he had an
influence on the type of rider
that I became.
People have a lot of ways to
describe
Mark Twain but to describe him
as a satirist, so a satirist is
somebody who finds a way to
use comedy to better inform
people about some serious issue
that's going on. And that's
always been a really interesting
way for me to communicate.
Something that has influenced
me, even though there's maybe
not a specific book of Mark
Twain's that I would look to for
inspiration.
>> Hi my name is Shakela and I
was
wondering where did you find the
notes for the book, to write the
book?
>> Remember the video we watched
at the beginning?
That was the Mark Twain paper
that is
its own little archive and
library in Berkeley California.
So at the time they made that
video, which I'm guessing was
about 20 years
ago they said that there were I
think about 10,000 letters to
and from Mark Twain.
Today it's all the way up to
over 30,000.
And they are still finding,
every
single week, as many as three
new letters written to either
Mark Twain or
from Mark Twain or from a family
member of Mark Twain. So the
archive is really a living thing
where things are constantly
coming in and new things are
being discovered and there have
got to be any number of little
pieces of gold stuck in this
archive waiting to be discovered
by people.
>> My name is Amani and I was
wondering
why do you think that you were
chosen to rewrite this book?
>> I have asked myself that too,
and I don't have an answer that
I can say is definitely the true
answer.
But what I think is the reason
we were chosen is actually the
ability of my wife Erin.
So I really think it is her
ability as an artist and the
methods I was showing
you, how she works in woodblock,
she works with these traditional
materials, I
think that Erin was a bridge
between Mark Twain's era and my
own and I just kind of came
along because I was attached to
her. That's what I tell people,
anyway.
>> We've got time for one more
question. And we will...
>> Hello, so my name is Odon and
so
before you wrote the book did
you know what was in Mark
Twain's mind like you
don't know the way it was like,
the book
was ended, like what was in his
mind? Did you figure out this?
Or did you take your time?
>> So the most difficult part of
this job was figuring out what
was actually inside the mind of
this writer and instead of
trying to figure out what was
in his mind on that very
specific day,
what I tried to figure out was
what was on his mind throughout
his lifetime. And if I could
figure out what was on
his mind throughout his lifetime
I would have a better chance of
figuring out the way that he
would have told the story. Also
before I leave I want to make
sure that somebody gets me one
of these T-shirts that just says
Twain on it.
Because I don't have anything
quite like that so if... That
would be great.
>> Awesome.
Thank you all so much. Your
questions were terrific.
And thank you.
[Cheers and applause]
>> I also want
to, I also want to give a very
very special...
I want to give a very very
special thank you to Dr. and
Mrs.
Eskin who are here with us who
made this program possible.
Thank you.
[Cheers and applause]
>> As I mentioned at the
beginning of this program, Dr.
and Mrs.
Eskin are responsible for the
Jonah Skolkoff Memorial program
here at the
library and they have been
supporting this for nine years
and every one of these programs
I just think are marvelous.
I think your connection to the
story your way of telling it and
having it be about inspiration
and discovery is very
much a part of why you are here.
So thank you and thank you.
And thank you to those of you
watching on the live stream. We
love it when our audience gets
extended.
So thanks to all of you.
And I've got a couple of things
that I need to say to those of
you in the room before you head
out. So..
.